c'est sa grande corvée de recyclage
conrad mclaren rapporte quelques fois
par année toutes les bouteilles
consignées de bière de vin et de
spiritueux a cumulé à la maison jamais
il ne le ferait si elle devait être
rapportée dans des établissements
différents
en ontario c'est dans les 8 135 magasins
de la bannière beer store qu'on recycle
les bouteilles d'alcool consignes et de
toutes sortes
l'arrière boutique a d'ailleurs des
allures de véritables centres de tri des
bouteilles de vin sont triés selon la
couleur du vert nous explique le
responsable du développement durable
pour les brasseurs du canada 300
millions de bouteilles de vins et de
spiritueux sont recyclés dans les
bistrots or chaque année la consigne est
de 20,5 pour celles de plus de 630
millilitres le gouvernement verse 10
cents par bouteille ou beer store pour
qu'ils en fassent le recyclage coût
annuel pour les ontariens 30 millions on
récupère jusqu'à 30% plus de bouteilles
que lorsque les gens les mettait dans
leurs bacs de recyclage affirme-t-il et
le verre aurait une plus grande valeur
puisqu'il n'est pas mélanger aux autres
matières recyclables
le taux de recyclage des bouteilles est
beaucoup moindre au manitoba et au
québec qu'ailleurs au pays dit il elles
sont les seules provinces à ne pas avoir
instauré le programme de consigne pour
les bouteilles de vins et de spiritueux
chaque programme a ses particularités en
alberta par exemple où l'entreprise
privée exploite les points de chute pour
le retour des bouteilles
la consigne grimpe même à 25 cents par
bouteille de plus d'un litre
il suffit du club la radio canada
toronto